questo nostro è stato fatto qualche anno
dopo in cui tramite le tengo ritmi
intelligenti che abbiamo creato apposta
siamo riusciti a dare la sensazione di
scivolamento degli oggetti
mentre venivano manipolati e quindi le
performance mi vengono comparate le
performance tra la l'utilizzo della
protesi con questa rigoni timo
intelligente e stimolazione del nervo e
senza aumentano di molto le capacità
unico la tv
ma oltre a pensare al controllo motorio
e al feedback sensoriale quindi
semplicemente alle performance quando si
va dall interazione con la tecnologia
soprattutto con delle protesi è
fondamentale la domanda ma come si fa a
far diventare quelle protesi parte del
loro corpo perché quando l'imputato
perde una mano non perde solo uno
strumento funzionale soprattutto per gli
amputati monolaterale alla fine molti
dei compiti riescono a farli con l'altra
mano quello che perde è l'integrità
della rappresentazione del proprio corpo
e quando le pensiamo a una parte del
nostro corpo alla nostra mamma lina è
scontato dire ok questa è la mia mano
però i processi che il cervello deve
fare per riconoscere che quella è la
propria mano non sono così semplici
quello che succede e che tira presente
in maniera molto schematica e che noi
abbiamo delle cortecce sensoriali e
primarie come la corteccia
somatosensoriale primaria e la corteccia
visiva che sono fatte per ricevere le
informazioni soltanto da et al tatto
dalla recensione o della visione quindi
sono pro specie
monomodali ricevono l'informazione
soltanto la modalità sensoriale poi ci
sono delle cortecce di ordine superiore
che sono delle cortecce integrative che
mettono insieme informazioni da dai
sensi da più sensi per esempio il tappo
la visione e li mettono insieme tramite
processi di formazione nel tempo e nello
spazio
mettendole insieme riescono a costruire
dei rapporti di causalità di causa
effetto
e questo lo fanno ci sono alcune cellule
studiate molto particolari che hanno il
campo ricettivo visivo quindi idolo
vengono attivati questi neuroni quando
succede qualcosa nello spazio e ricevono
anche il campo recettoriale tattile dal
nostro corpo e questi due campi si
attivano contemporaneamente queste
cellule sono particolari perché hanno un
campo visivo che è bloccato sulle parti
del corpo quindi loro si attivano quando
ad esempio uno stimolo visivo è vicino
alla mano si sa se in questa parte del
campo visivo si sa se non spostiamo alla
mano in un'altra parte del campo visivo
quindi queste cellule l'attivazione di
questi neuroni codifica per il nostro
corpo sono loro che ci dicono la tua
mano è tua e parte del tuo corpo questa
tra le implicazioni molto importanti
perché non solo ci dicono come è fatto
il nostro corpo ma ci dicono chi siamo
dove siamo posizionati nello spazio e
come vedremo tra un attimo ci dicono
anche che stiamo agendo che ci stiamo
muovendo
e su questi su questi spunti è partito
poi un
progetto di nars in starting grant che
ha dato la possibilità poi di finanziare
anche gli studi che vedrete proprio
sulle body mentre quindi
l'incorporazione l'incarnazione di
protesi
sensorizzati e interfacciate a livello
direttamente col sistema nervoso
centrale
da qui siamo andati oltre perché abbiamo
pensato che non è soltanto importante la
relazione con le protesi da un punto di
vista di comando e di feedback
sensoriale ma anche di continuità fisica
col con logico il corpo stesso cioè tra
la protesi e il corpo stesso ed ecco
adesso non soltanto no diciamo l'e'quipe
il gruppo allargato con delle
interazioni molte importanti con dei
gruppi che stanno in svezia si riesce si
riesce a fare per la prima volta in
italia è una delle prime volte al mondo
lustro integrazione delle protesi quindi
riusciamo a impiantare un po come si fa
con le protesi di anca come se vado a
tempo con le protesi di anca riusciamo
impiantare un chiodo endomidollare
nel nel
l'osso del paziente amputato
e a questo chiodo attaccare con un
aggancio rapido direttamente la protesi
che diventa una continuità quindi
abbiamo una continuità reale tra
artificiale e biologico e questa
continuità ci permette anche di far
passare dei cavi che vanno i muscoli i
tagli ai membri del soggetto quindi
adesso voi vedete questo ragazzo un
altro un altro che ci ha permesso di
andare molto avanti che quella scienza
roberto che sgancia e aggancia la sua
protesi in un attimo senza problemi di
socket di imbragatura che sono
drammatici per i pazienti e imputati
da qui il prossimo passo era quello di
creare questo ibrido bionico questo
sistema di video bionico tra l'umano e
l'artificiale e fino adesso però è una
cosa reale però mostrata in maniera
reale ma finora fino adesso ha
riguardato soltanto pazienti amputati
con protesi di mano a questa cosa può
andare a toccare anche ambiti diversi
quindi il soggetto sano con delle
abilità motori normali che utilizza dei
robot sovranumerari degli altri
soprannome e questo è il nuovo passo che
stiamo facendo non soltanto a noi
diciamo ci siamo in tema di fertilità
internazionale in cui si parla di human
auto mente show newman enhancement
quindi aumento delle capacità fisiche
sia motorie e cognitive noi in
particolare ci occupiamo soprattutto di
quel senso di motorie quindi soggetti
sani che controllano terzi alti robotici
per dei compiti particolarmente
rischiosi oppure perché ci vuole una
destrezza immaginate in alcuni ambiti
chirurgici
oppure perché va valutato se è più
importante fare dei compiti in più
persone o semplicemente una singola
persona che con tre o più arti riesce ad
avere una maggiore destrezza
ovviamente per controllare un robot
assieme alle proprie mani si aprono
tutta una serie di problemi di
interfacce motorie e sensoriali
noi oltre che
ridare il feedback tramite interfaccia
invasive che questo al momento non è
proponibile ovviamente quando ho detto
sanno deve controllare un altro può dire
soprannumerario lo facciamo andare anche
in maniera non invasiva questo ad
esempio è una una collega del
laboratorio che
riceve un feedback dallo spostamento di
un robot è bendata riesce a emularlo e
questo tipo e che viene ridato tramite
un un'illusione conosciuta che stimola
provoca una vibrazione che stimola
proprio quegli organi nei muscoli che ci
dicono ci danno la propriocezione la
propriocezione è un sesto senso che noi
tutti abbiamo anche se non siamo così
consci di avere che per esempio occhi
chiusi ci dice se il nostro corpo a gli
altri flessi o estesi quindi la
propriocezione è un po york sono un po
gli occhi del nostro corpo
andando avanti
su questa linea come si può studiare le
embodiment quindi come il paziente
amputato
riesce a interiorizzare far diventare la
protesi parte del proprio corpo sentirsi
di nuovo integro si può fa traslare e
andare a studiare come il soggetto sa
non può ipotizzare anche un altro
sovrannumerario questo sembra un po un
controsenso perché il nostro corpo è
sempre stato quello da quando siamo ma
non è così si è dimostrato come soggetti
sani riescono imbonitore tre arti tre
mani o addirittura corpi virtuali o
corpi di smorti c per esempio delle cose
finte quindi tutto questo si può fare
trovando la chiave di accesso ai giusti
meccanismi cerebrali
e andando avanti questi meccanismi
cerebrali si possono non solo studiare
ma anche modulare ci sono delle tecniche
che si conoscano già da tanti anni ad
esempio la stimolazione magnetica
transcranica la stimolazione magnetica
transcranica
attiva artificialmente i nostri neuroni
creando un campo magnetico variabile nel
tempo che genera delle con desk correnti
indotte è come sapete i neuroni si
esprimono in correnti fondamentalmente
quindi creando una corrente nelle nostre
cortecce noi riusciamo ad attivare i
nostri neuroni tutto questo fino adesso
è stato fatto con sistemi manuali
mentre c'è l'operatore che si metterà
con la bobina e stimola il soggetto per
attivare i neuroni
il prossimo passo quale mettere la
robotica l'intelligenza artificiale
anche dentro la simulazione non invasiva
artificiale e questo come vedete un
sistema robotico anche qui finanziato da
universi prof concept che sviluppa una
stimolazione che lo sviluppo quindi a
ciclo chiuso che sente l'effetto della
stimolazione e sento i movimenti del
soggetto in maniera automatica
ricompensa
quindi qui si può dire vai a stimolare
un aria perché vuoi creare una funzione
da si è imposta e il robot la fa in
maniera automatica questo sono già dei
meccanismi terapeutici approvati per
esempio nella depressione farmaco
resistente ma un impatto grandissimo in
tantissime altre patologie dalla
riabilitazione post ictus
all'elezione al
parkinson e tante altre patologie
quindi questo è un po il quadro generale
in cui ci muoviamo è
tutta questa forte interazione che oggi
abbiamo quella tecnologia va a
ridisegnare un po quelli che sono stati
i classici concerti studiati dalle
neuroscienze ad esempio ci sono degli
studi sono state delle dette degli studi
chiave che sono stati fatti
70 negli anni 80 che hanno dimostrato
come se una scimmia o anche un soggetto
anche un umano un soggetto sano
utilizza il le proprie dita e le prime
li allena per per provare delle
superfici la rappresentazione in
corteccia nelle corteccia
somatosensoriale
cresce quindi e queste sono delle prime
dimostrazioni della plasticità cerebrale
che ha rivoluzionato l'ambito delle
neuroscienze
però tutti può essere un degli studi in
cui ancora si studiava l'interazione con
l'ambiente ideale con l'ambiente
materiale ma mai immaginate quello che
può essere utilizzare sempre lo stesso
dito però per andare su un tablet a fare
una gita virtuale nel louvre il concetto
del tanto cambia completamente e cambia
completamente anche come questo per i
modulari disegna la nostra la
rappresentazione cerebrale quindi tutto
questo chiaramente richiede un ripensare
i paradigmi di neuroscienze nell'ottica
dell'interazione tra l'uomo e la
tecnologia perché sta cambiando il
nostro modo di comportarci le
neuroscienze studiano i processi
cerebrali dietro i nostri comportamenti
da qui
il prossimo passo se riesco a premere il
pulsante
ecco è il rischio di tutto questo c'è un
rischio molto forte che viene che ci
viene oggi l'imputato
data dai filosofi degli eticisti che
quello del trans mese di andare oltre
quello che l'umano per generare una
nuova specie che non è più ma è diciamo
questo rischio è concreto e concreto
perchè perchè come avete visto la
tecnologia si fa più antropomorfa i
limiti del corpo diventano blair
diventano i toni di grigio il nostro
corpo è il misto di tecnologia e i
confini non sono più così definiti sono
un po dati di segnali sono fluidi e
e potremmo veramente andare oltre l'uomo
non tanto perché come alcuni pensano
perché la tecnologia
l'intelligenza artificiale
riesce ad auto e riprodursi quindi da
oltre l'uomo questo io non lo vedo un
rischio concreto ad oggi magari tra 50
anni o 100 anni non so però oggi il
problema è che stati i limiti confini di
ciò che biologico e ciò che artificiale
diventano veramente difficili da
stabilire che diventano il napoli
continua evoluzione e quindi non
possiamo fare a meno cioè non possiamo
evitare che questo processo avvenga ma
dobbiamo in qualche modo
governarlo e come lo governiamo equa
ritorniamo al fattore
dobbiamo
essere certi che i limiti del
dell'essere uomo ciò che ci definisce
come uomo non sono i confini del nostro
corpo non sono non è come noi siamo
fatti ma sono i confini delle nostre
azioni
cioè come noi agiamo e come noi agiamo
viene studiato ci sono viene chiamata
agency cioè la nostra capacità di
rendersi conto che noi siamo la causa
delle nostre azioni
dobbiamo trasportare la nostra agency
alle macchine ai dispositivi artificiali
e questo è un tema fortissimo
nell'ambito della tecnologia poi pensate
all'automotive all'automatico e
controllata tramite intelligenza
artificiale
ci sono stati degli scoli andati sul
manager su science sulle vista
importantissime che hanno cercato di
capire quale deve essere la morale di
questa intelligenza artificiale cioè
come mentre il fattore umano perché
l'intelligenza artificiale non può aver
morale non ancora le fate i conti può
essere molto brava da prendere questi
conti oggi può utilizzare la storia
pregressa però non riesce a capire se è
meglio sterzare o andar dritto quando
davanti c'è una scelta morale i dilemmi
morali sono quando in entrambe le
situazioni c'è qualcosa da perdere
qualcosa da guadagnare e quindi per
questo si sono intervistati 40 milioni
di persone in diversi paesi e si è
capito si è capito si è cercato di
capire quale diverse colture considerano
gli stimoli più importanti da un punto
di vista morale le leggi
immaginate questo come vuoi riguardare
l'ambito della women fashion cioè di
superare le nostre capacità normali
perché si modifica il corpo c tab e le
potenzialità oltre quelle che sono le
potenzialità degli altri e quando si sta
in società un patto implicito che tutti
devono avere le stesse potenzialità
perché sennò si smette di fidarci l'uno
dell'altro
come facciamo a sviluppare nuovi
arti sovranumerari che
piattaforme di human auto mente shaun
quindi
aumenta me avente azione populu trillian
delle nostre capacità motorie
se non
trasportando la responsabilità che
tipica dell'uomo che è un fattore umano